[MUSIC PLAYING]
HENRY SHI: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for having me here.
So before I start, just
curious how many of you
are working on AI stuff?
Raise your hand.
Oh, a lot.
So today, my topic is
"AI Startup Ecosystem
in the US and China."
I will provide some
comparative perspectives
on the two ecosystems.
So many of you have noticed
that AI startups grow rapidly.
So if you look at AI
unicorns-- "unicorns"
meaning startups have over
$1 billion valuations--
there are 32 AI
unicorns by 2018.
So this is reported
by CB Insights.
This is about 10% of
the whole unicorn club.
And this percentage
is continue growing.
Note that there's 17 companies
from US, 10 from China.
So it looks like US has
more AI unicorns than China.
But if we look at
this figure, we
look at top five most-funded
AI unicorns, actually
China has three.
And the most two well-funded
AI unicorns are from China.
Maybe you are not familiar
with some of the companies.
I will provide you a
little bit background.
The first well-funded
company is called ByteDance.
Actually, they have a big
office in Culver City.
ByteDance raised $3 billion.
It's a Chinese company.
It has a number of products,
but the two main products, one
is Toutiao, which is
AI-powered news app.
It has over 500 million
monthly active users.
The second one, which is
probably more popular,
called TikTok, they
have over 500 million
monthly active users globally.
This is a AI-powered
short video sharing app.
If you haven't used
it, please have a try.
Now, the second well-funded AI
company is called SenseTime.
The company raised $2.6 billion,
and focuses on computer vision.
Now, SenseTime has over
700 enterprise customers
and strategic partners globally.
It has applications over
more than 10 industries.
The main technology, or
product, of SenseTime
is facial recognition.
Their facial recognition
service is serving
over 400 million people.
So the fifth well-funded
company is called UBTech.
It's another Chinese company.
This company is building
this service robotics.
This looks human-like robotics,
are produced by UBTech.
There's a lot of robotics.
So the revenue in 2018 is
actually over $300 million.
So they sell these
robots very well.
And their sales increased over
500 times within four years.
Now, if we look at the two
other companies from the US,
they are autonomous driving
companies, Nuro and Argo.
They both raised $1 billion.
Nuro is a little bit different.
They are building
this self-driving car
for food delivery,
while it can also
deliver other stuff later on.
Argo AI is more like standard
self-driving car company.
They're building
self-driving cars.
We notice that these five top
most well-funded AI companies,
they are all funded
within a few years.
And there are so
many other unicorns.
They grow so rapidly.
So the question I want to ask
is, why are these AI startups
growing so rapidly?
There are a couple of reasons.
First, there's
continuous progress
in data processing, computing
power, and algorithms.
If we look at these
two figures, this
is some statistics
on ImageNet data set.
I think many of you
should know that.
If we look at the classification
accuracy on ImageNet data set,
the accuracy
continues to improve.
In 2014, and actually after
2014, it beats humans,
and now it continues to improve.
Another very
interesting observation
is that in the past year
or two, the training time
on the ImageNet to building
these machine learning models
actually drops
dramatically, thanks
to all this parallel
computing, cloud computing.
Now, the second reason for the
rapid growth of AI companies
is the significant growth
of venture capital into AI.
So this figure shows the global
AI investments year by year.
We can see that the trend is
that VC money is growing year
by year into AI.
And in 2008, the VC
money total actually
is 70% up, compared to 2017.
Now, this curve actually
shows the number of deals.
So interestingly,
in 2018, the number
of deals that raised
money is actually
fewer than that in 2017.
And we observe large
rounds, but fewer deals.
Fewer deals meaning
fewer companies
actually raised money.
So why is that?
Why, given that so
much money is into AI,
but money are concentrated on
deals, on these fewer deals?
There are a couple of reasons.
But the main point is
that in some AI fields,
the bigger gets bigger.
Basically, big
companies, big startups,
are easier to
attract more money.
So there are a
couple of reasons.
So one is the data
network effect,
because these AI unicorns tend
to collect more and more data.
And these data actually
provide the company
more advances in technology.
Secondly, these AI
unicorns are easier
to attract more AI talents.
And you know more
AI talents means
you have more power, in terms
of technology development.
Certainly, these AI
unicorns are easier
to expand to more territories.
TikTok, as I said, the
core product of ByteDance,
they are actually expanded
to the US, Asia, and Europe.
Now they have over 500 million
monthly active users globally.
The fourth reason is that these
bigger AI startups can expand
to more industries easier.
SenseTime, as
example, they already
covers over 10 industries.
Now, a natural question
to ask is, will there
be more capital into AI?
Probably yes.
If you look at US VC
market, 2018 is actually
a record-breaking year.
So this shows the
total venture capital
money raised by US startups.
In 2018, the amount is
significantly larger
than 2017 and the years before.
So looks like this is great
timing for US AI startups,
because there's a lot
of money in the market.
What about China?
In 2017, actually, the AI
funding, the VC money in China,
exceeds the US.
The total funding in
China is about 48%
of the total AI
funding globally,
while US has only 78%--
sorry, 38%.
But things are getting changing.
So if you look at this
figure, starting from 2018,
so the number of deals and also
the amount of venture capital
money in China is decreasing.
So in China, startups
and VCs are facing
so-called "capital winter."
Why is that?
There's multiple reasons.
One reason is the
slowing economy of China.
And secondly also, because
of the falling share
price of the tech giants,
people are afraid of the market.
There could be
some other reasons,
but the main point is that
in China, the VC market
is different.
It's getting changing.
And this may challenge
the Chinese AI unicorns.
The third reason for the
rapid growth of AI unicorns
is the thriving
industry applications.
Nowadays, you can
see AI unicorns
are solving big problems
in almost each industry you
can imagine.
I will go through
these details later.
But these massive application
drives the rapid growth
of AI unicorns.
Now, let's ask a second
important question.
Why do some AI companies grow
so rapidly in one country,
but not in the other?
We notice that companies
like ByteDance,
like SenseTime, they are big
in China, but not in the US.
In the US, these
autonomous driving startups
raised a lot of money,
but not same in China.
So why is that?
So to answer this
question, actually we
have four key observations.
So first, for R&D,
US is ahead of China.
Secondly, for manufacturing,
China has its own advantages.
Thirdly, for B2B
industries, US is stronger.
So what is B2B?
B2B stands for
business to business,
meaning the customers
are enterprises.
Well, for B2C and B2G,
China is stronger.
B2C stands for
business to consumer.
All the customers are consumers.
B2G, G stands for
government, meaning
you are serving government.
So for B2C and B2G,
China is stronger.
The fourth observation is
that Chinese unicorns actually
are adopting some unique
growth strategies.
So I will come to these
observations one by one.
First, R&D, US is
ahead of China.
Now, if we look at AI talents,
so if we look at the talents
in all AI companies, US is about
1.5x of the number of talents
in China.
The difference is
not that significant.
But if we look at the
number of top AI talents,
US has much more advantage.
The top AI talents in
the US is 5.3 times
of the number in China.
All these AI talents are
very important for R&D,
for developing these
disruptive technologies.
Another example is to looking
at the autonomous driving
technology.
This is sort of
integrated AI technology,
because you are building
a complex system.
This figure is very interesting.
It's published by DMV in 2018.
It shows the miles
per disengagement.
What does it mean?
It means, how many miles
can a self-driving car drive
until a human gets involved?
So we can see that the first one
is Waymo, developed by Google.
Waymo is obviously the top
one, in terms of the test.
But this is in 2018.
For now, Google is
absolute leader.
In this chart, US
has 16 companies.
China has four.
Looks like US self-driving
cars companies
are much more than China
and other countries.
Nuro, Aurora, are
also doing well.
You notice that the top five
companies are from the US,
meaning they are ahead of China.
Interestingly, Nuro and Aurora
are founded by ex-Googles.
So Waymo is a leader in
self-driving car technology.
It has built a large
pool of talents.
Waymo actually developed
the technology 10 years ago.
And the larger pool of
talent developed by Waymo
actually helped other
self-driving cars
to do their technologies.
So Google made a big
impact in the space.
Now, the second observation
is that manufacturing in China
has its unique advantages.
Why is that?
Because there is relatively
low cost of labors
and raw materials in China.
Manufacturing
infrastructure are mature.
Highways, roads, and ports
in China are well-developed.
Thirdly, there's detailed
division of tasks.
So the pipeline of
manufacturing is very mature.
Examples are UBTech Robotics.
They can produce this kind
of robotics in fairly cheaper
price than anywhere else.
Xiaomi is another great example.
Xiaomi builds an
ecosystem of smart devices
in relatively cheaper price.
So the takeaway
for the US startups
is that you can leverage
these manufacturing
advantages in China.
Good examples are Lime and Bird.
They are building these
scooters which you
can see a lot in Santa Monica.
Actually, these scooters are
mainly developed in China,
and these companies can cover
the cost just within 20 days.
Turing is one
example, the company
we invested, doing
security robots.
It can patrol
indoors and outdoors.
Because the hardware are
manufactured in China,
it's 80% cheaper than
its US competitors.
So companies here should trying
to leverage the hardware cost
advantage in China.
So the third observation
is really important.
So in B2B space, US startups are
stronger, where in B2C and B2G,
Chinese startups are stronger.
So we actually calculated
the average funding
of the top three
startup in each industry
where AI is applying to.
So the first part
is the industries
that US startups raised
much more capital
than those in China.
And for the second
part, these are
industries where Chinese
startups raised more money.
And if we dig into
these two parts,
we find that these industries
are more B2B industries, where
your customers are
typically enterprises, where
the second part,
your customers are
more like consumers
and also government.
So let's explain, why is that?
In the US, B2B ecosystem
is well-established.
That means AI startups can
get access to data easier.
You see all kinds of
SaaS-model-based companies
are very well-developed
in the US.
And also, AI has a clear
values to enterprises,
because AI can help
enterprises to lower the cost,
to improve the efficiency.
That's why, in the US,
a lot of enterprises
are trying AI
technologies to help them.
What about China?
China is different.
In China, US B2B ecosystem
is not well-established.
The trust ecosystem,
the trust system,
is not as well as
developed in the US.
Also, because of the low
cost of human labors,
enterprises in China
tend to hire more people,
instead of trying to
using AI to lower the cost
or improve the efficiency.
And also, in China, B2C has
higher growth and more data.
So startups doing B2C space
can access data much easier.
And in China, you will see
that the mobile internet
users are growing very fast.
The last reason is
B2G has a higher
revenue and more data in China.
So in China, Chinese
government is highly
supportive on AI startups.
They give a lot of data to
startups like SenseTime.
So by working with government,
these big AI unicorns
can access more data, and they
can also get big contracts
from Chinese governments.
So this what drives the high
growth of these companies.
I want to just talk a
little bit about B2C space
in China, where you can
access much more data.
If you look at this
curve, in China,
there's three times active
mobile devices than the US.
And the number of
food delivery orders
is much more, like
10 times in the US.
But this is in 2017.
I think today, US has
more food delivery.
You see DoorDash, Postmates, all
kind of delivering companies.
And also, the mobile payments in
China is 50 times than the US.
So you can get access to
these consumer-based data
fairly easily.
And you know AI is
building on data.
So this is key.
Let me give you some example.
One example in B2B industry is
robotics process automation,
where AI can automating large
amount of repetitive works.
The typical example is UiPath.
This company raised
about $500 million.
Their revenue grow from
$1 million to $100 million
within only 21 months.
You can see that US enterprise
are paying a lot of money
for these type of company.
And it has over 2,000
enterprise customers globally.
So another B2B space
is cybersecurity.
US enterprises
paying a lot of money
for cybersecurity
companies to using
AI to help them to detect
and defend these attacks.
One company, CrowdStrike, they
raised around $500 million.
They actually analyze a
trillion events per week.
And it prevent about
30,000 breaches per year.
Very significant.
Another example is agriculture,
where the company Plenty, they
can do over 300 times crop
yield than traditional farms,
and only using 1% of water.
So you can see AI plays
a significant role here,
in terms of improving
the efficiency.
Let's look at some example
the B2C space, where
Chinese startups is stronger.
Entertainment is one example.
You can use AI to
do personalization,
using AI to do intelligent
recommendation.
ByteDance is a good
example, as I mentioned.
Another industry,
service robotics.
Companies like UBTech are
producing this all kinds
of robotics to serve people,
to interact with people, where
AI plays an important role
of perceiving the environment
and interact with people.
A good example of B2G is
the physical security space,
where Chinese government
is highly supportive
and give big
contracts to startups.
Let's look at some number.
In China, 170 million
security cameras are deployed,
and you can expect
400 million more.
So there's way more number of
security cameras than the US.
SenseTime is the
leader in the space,
but you also notice other
competitors from China--
FaceTime, CloudWork,
[INAUDIBLE],,
all raised big amount of money.
So the B2G space
in China actually
attracts a lot of capital.
I also want to mention that
B2B space in China is booming.
Although you see that US is
stronger in B2B, but now,
Chinese companies are paying
more attention to the space.
Why is that?
Because the labor costs
is increasing, because
of the aging population.
Now enterprises in China are
paying more attention to cost.
Secondly, the high growth
of mobile internet users,
the growth rate is diminishing.
Now Chinese companies are
looking at B2B space more,
because you couldn't have such
big growth in B2C anymore,
for most field.
We can see some example.
For example, UBTech, they are
building intelligent inspection
robots that can patrol
and find safety risks.
SenseTime is also
doing remote sensing.
They work on satellite data.
They attract
insights of the data,
then can apply to
industries like agriculture.
Now, the takeaway
for the US startups
is that if you are doing
something in B2B space,
it's huge opportunity to
expand that to China market.
One example is DataVisor.
It's a US company
backed by Sequoia.
They actually serving a
lot of customers in the US,
but also in China.
You can see customers
like Alibaba, Jingdong,
and some other social apps,
big social apps, in China.
They started in the US, but now
they expand heavily in China.
Another takeaway is that if
you are working on B2C or B2G
space, actually you can learn
a lot from China's practice,
because Chinese
startups have tried
really hard in these spaces.
Because B2B is tougher, they
tried harder in B2C and B2G.
And they have explored various
possibilities in these spaces.
Let's look at some example.
Facial recognition-- you can
see that facial recognition
technologies in China have
been applied to every industry
you can imagine, from
education, finance, health care,
entertainment, auto, security.
Many industries here.
You can imagine it's
way more ahead of US.
Another interesting example
is license plate recognition.
You can think this as a
easier computer vision task
to recognize the license
plate in your car.
Now, in China, many shopping
malls have these systems.
These systems will
recognize your license plate
when you get into the
parking structure.
And when you get out,
it will automatically
count how much time you spent,
and you will pay for it.
No ticket needed.
And it improves the whole
traffic flow significantly.
So these systems are
broadly used in China now,
but it's still early in the US.
So for startups in the
US, it's good to look
at some applications in China.
Maybe some of them, you
can apply to the US too.
Another example is the
physical security space.
I mentioned this
company we invested,
they are doing security robots.
They actually learned a lot
from the B2G space in China.
These security robots will
patrol in office spaces
during off hours.
They will do human detection.
They will not do
facial recognition,
because people will have less
concern about their privacy.
But they will detect
humans and see
if there is some safety risks.
They will also collaborate with
the security guards in the US,
so that if there is
some risk discovered,
the robot will collaborate with
guards to resolve these risks.
Now, the fourth
observation we have
is that Chinese unicorns adopt
some unique growth strategies.
One strategy is the
horizontal expansion.
In China, there
are some unicorns
apply the core AI technologies
to multiple industries.
SenseTime is one example.
They applying their
computer vision technology
to over 10 industries.
And also, SenseTime
sets up its corporate VC
to invest into other
strategic partners.
They invest companies doing
entertainment, companies
doing AI with health
care, companies
doing AI with smart cities.
So SenseTime is actually doing
this horizontal expansion
to speed up its whole growth.
There's a number of
other AI unicorns
in China doing similar stuff.
Well, we notice that for
most AI unicorns in the US,
they're mainly
focusing on a vertical,
because they think it's
more capital-efficient.
We think the
horizontal expansion
can be applied to some
US AI startups too,
but not all of them.
The second interesting
strategy in China
is called multiple
revenue streams.
AI startups in China, they
will provide freemium models
for early adopters.
But how they make
money if this is free?
They can get revenues
from other streams.
Let's look at this license plate
recognition system as example.
So in China, when these
companies build these systems,
it's hard for them to sell to
these shopping mall owners,
because shopping
mall owners don't
want to pay much for that.
They say, oh, I don't
need you to pay anything.
I will give it to you for free.
But in exchange, let me put
some ads in the entrance.
Now they sell the
ads, advertisements,
to other companies,
to make money.
By doing so, it
covers their cost.
But later on, when more
and more shopping malls
have their systems,
it's easier for them
to sell to many
other shopping malls.
So actually, this is similar to
the B2C growth strategy, where
Google provide free
services for consumers,
so that the adoption
can be much faster.
So Chinese unicorns
actually applying
this interesting growth
strategy in B2C space
to B2B, because B2B
in China is so hard,
they need to think clever ways
to get into the B2C space,
to accelerate the adoption.
So why they try these
kind of growth strategies?
As I said, B2B is
tougher in China.
Customer adoption
is slow, so they
need to expand to multiple
industries as soon as possible.
Secondly, there's
growth pressure
from investors in China.
So in China, investors used
to seek B2C growth, which
is more like exponential growth,
where in B2B space is harder.
So you needed to expand
to multiple industries
to achieve faster growth.
And thirdly, there's
high pressure
from the fierce
competition in China.
So SenseTime is actually
competing with these companies
in a lot of industries.
These companies all raised
huge amount of money.
So the competition
is really high.
So these companies will try to
get into different industries
faster than competitors.
Now, the takeaway
for US startups
is that for some startups, you
can try horizontal expansion.
If you have a core technology,
and this technology
can be applied to
multiple industries,
you may try this kind
of growth strategy.
Some examples, like
self-driving technology,
you can apply to auto;
retail; security,
if you do security robots;
supply chain management, if you
can do robots in warehouses.
For robotic process automation,
and also for fraud detection,
you can try similar
strategy, because it can
be applied to many industries.
Secondly, the takeaway
on the multiple revenue
streams, I think US B2B startups
can think of other revenue
stream than just a customer
subscribe your services.
This actually can speed
up the customer adoption.
If you apply this
strategy in the US,
maybe you can go much faster
than your competitors.
So lastly, I want to talk
about some opportunities
for US startups.
So first, you can get
into more markets--
as I mentioned, China and
other emerging markets.
So secondly, US startups can
learn from China's practices,
especially in B2C
and B2G spaces.
Thirdly, it's interesting to
looking at industries with less
competition, so there are
more opportunities for people
to start new AI startups.
Fourthly, companies should
leverage some new tech trends
in AI.
So for the third
opportunity, startups
can step into industries
with less competition.
So we probe the numbers.
We find that for
certain industries,
there's high capital
concentration,
meaning startups already
raised large rounds of capital.
So the competition can be high.
But for new startups, it's
good to look at some industries
with less competition--
for example, education, travel,
energy, retail, space tech,
agriculture, materials,
and many others.
So in these spaces,
no company actually
raised huge round of capital.
So it's easier for
startups to get into.
There's less competition.
So maybe it's good to pay
attention to these industries.
So the fourth opportunity is
to look at the new technology
trends in AI.
I briefly summarized
into three categories.
One is for data
processing, AIoT--
AI plus IoT-- edge
computing, 5G.
These technology all allow
more real-time processing
of large volume of data.
Second category is
computing power.
For example, tensor
processing unit, TPU,
is powered by Google.
I think it's a good
technology to leverage,
to speed up the
whole AI computation.
Quantum computing is on the way.
We may still need to wait
a few years before it
gets more better developed.
But it's promising.
The third category is
the new algorithms.
Again, as one
example, you can use
it to generate very
real fake images.
For example, some
companies are using
GAN to generate faked
training data for AI systems.
You don't need to
get a lot of data.
Now you can use an algorithm
to generate more training data.
Some companies are
thinking of applying
GAN to do some creation work.
Transfer learning, where
you apply your AI technology
from one industry
to others, you can
transfer some
knowledge you already
learned in one industry.
If you also expand your system
from one country to others,
transfer learning
can be also helpful.
Federated learning-- you
can do collaborative machine
learning without
centralized training data.
You can do more like
distributed computing
when training a large system.
OK.
To summarize, today I shared
with you four key observations.
First, in R&D, US
is ahead of China.
Secondly, for
manufacturing, China
has some advantages that
US company can leverage.
Thirdly, B2B, US
is ahead of China.
But in B2C and B2G,
Chinese companies
are actually very strong.
So it's good for B2B companies
here to expand to China.
And also, for B2C
and B2G industries,
US startups can learn
from China's success.
The fourth observation
is Chinese unicorns
adopt unique growth strategies.
I think for most
startup in the US,
maybe you could learn something
from China's growth strategies,
so that you can get
faster customer adoption.
And opportunities for
the US companies--
first, go into more markets.
Secondly, you can learn
from China's practices.
Thirdly, get into industries
with less competition.
I think there is a huge
amount of opportunities
for AI startups to do.
You can solve big problems
in these industries
with less competition.
Lastly, pay attention to
these new tech trends,
and you can leverage
some of the technology
to build your unicorn
in the future.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]